you're talking about the richest man in
the world possibly the smart one of the
smartest great brains in the world
uh one of the best trolls in the world
one of the most necessary forces
in the world where the people that are
not fans of you you know
can't stand him that's enemy to state
number one
they don't like the fact that he can
just drop
44 billion dollars and to be able to buy
twitter or do anything he's doing what
do you what do you think about elon musk
man i love elon and i love that he has
he is a man of purpose and i have so
much respect for men of purpose most
people who get his kind of paycheck
whenever he got it in the 90s would have
just cashed out hedonism
he decided to risk it all again to try
and achieve the most impossible things
that's how you got to where you are so
where i got to where i am when you have
enough to stop but you don't stop for
some reason there's some new mountain to
climb and that is what's beautiful about
men as a whole